[Música]
en lo que la pasión
busque la definición en google
y decía sentimiento vehemente capaz de
dominar la voluntad y perturbar el
corazón
como el amor
el odio
los celos o la ira intensa
para mí la pasión es algo que te atrae
algo que te motiva para
saber decir o hacer aún más
quieres ser el mejor
y simplemente
además a hacerlo
cuando tenía seis años
me fui con mi papá a visitarla mi abuela
en santa rosa de río primero
eran las once de la noche terminamos de
comer
y ya que hacía mucho calor decidimos ir
afuera
'llevamos reposeras mantas toallas
y nos acostamos ahí en el pasto
yo como cualquier niño estaba
mirando las estrellas que en ese momento
obviamente yo no sabía lo que eran
de repente ve una luz pasar rápido
y lo mira mi papá y le digo que era eso
y él me dice rápido hijo pedí un deseo
que es una estrella fugaz claro yo no
sabía si pedir el deseo o no
pero lo que hice fue preguntarme que era
una estrella fugaz
que era cada puntito que veía en el
cielo que ese gran círculo blanco que
veía
a mis nueve años descubrí que era una
estrella fugaz descubrí que eran las
estrellas
descubrí que era nuestro sol
y descubrí que era la tierra
descubrí que había mucho más planetas
muchas más estrellas
estaba ilusionado me gustaba saber esas
cosas
busque información sobre uno de los
hallazgos más importantes en la
astronomía y es que nosotros la tierra
incluso nuestro sol giramos alrededor de
sagitario
y se preguntarán qué es sectario ah es
un agujero negro supermasivo que está
ubicado en el centro de nuestra galaxia
imagínense en un granito de arroz
y una pelota de playa el granito de
arroz en nuestro gran sol y la pelota de
playa 'sagitario' pueden verlo realmente
pequeño que somos
suena aterrador incomprensible y capaz
el escape de la imagen de la imaginación
pero es real
a veces el ser humano se cree que es lo
más grande
lo más poderoso pero allá arriba hay
cosas mucho más grandes
mucho más poderosas
como dije sagitario a es un agujero
negro y sabían que los agujeros negros
expulsan rayos de vez en cuando
si nos golpean pueden hacernos
desaparecer en un abrir y cerrar de ojos
parpadea y ya no existís miles y miles
de años de historia borradas en tan solo
en menos de una fracción de segundo
un científico llamado isaac newton
estaba sentado en la sombra de un árbol
leyendo un libro
hasta que se le cae una manzana en la
cabeza igual que qué sorpresa
diga menos ustedes
quien quien pudo haber agarrado esa
manzana comérsela o tirarla a otro lado
y seguir en lo suyo
tal vez muchos pero isaac newton agarro
la manzana y se preguntó
porque se le había caído la manzana en
la cabeza
empiezo a sacar teorías y teorías
hasta que descubrió la gravedad
y quiero decirles con todo esto que con
una simple acción les puede llevar
a descubrir cosas con solo mirar hacia
la derecha hacia la izquierda o arriba o
abajo se les pueden abrir las puertas a
un sinfín de universos
las personas están rodeadas por muchas
oportunidades ocultas atrás de una
puerta
y les pasa algo me gustaría que se
pregunten por qué se les pasó
tal vez así
se vuelvan famosos científicos
d
encuentra su pasión
o tal vez se encuentre en un billete de
100 pesos
isaac newton
descubrió la gravedad
yo descubrí yo descubrí mi pasión
que descubrieran ustedes
gracias
i
[Música]